(foreboding, anxious music)
- Yo, we are going to be so rich
once we rob this lady.
- Zack, you are a genius.
- Aye, don't call me Zack,
call me by my code name.
- I'm sorry, Matterhorn.
- I forgive you, Jungle Cruise.
(chuckles)
- What's wrong with you, Small World?
- Ah God, I really dislike
the name Small World.
- Well would you feel better
if we called you Thunder Mountain?
- No, no, no you guys, it's not the name.
I just don't understand why our code names
have to be Disney theme park rides.
- Well, why not?
- Yeah, everyone likes Disneyland.
- Not everyone, I don't like Disneyland.
(gasps)
- What, what?
- Are you serious?
- Yes, I mean I just don't get the appeal.
- What?
- Do you even have a heart?
- Yes I have a heart.
In all honesty, I've never
even been to Disneyland, so.
- What!?
- Okay, okay, hold on, hold on.
How can you hate something
you've never even experienced?
What, excuse me, Justin hates broccoli.
Yet he's never had broccoli.
- They look like little trees.
I don't see how anybody eats them.
- Okay yeah, but this is Disneyland.
Disneyland's the best.
- The best.
- What makes it the best?
- It's beautiful.
- It's magical.
- The time stops when you're there.
- You don't have a fret in this world.
- Is the food reasonably priced?
- Like honestly, I can justify spending
11 dollars on a corn dog,
cause it's that good.
- Okay, listen, I've seen the commercials
it's too crowded, and I don't like that.
- Okay it gets a little crowded,
but when you're there, it's
like we're one big happy family.
- Sounds like trash.
- You are a monster!
- Oh my God!
- Hey lady, do you like Disneyland?
- What? Get out of my house,
I'm gonna call the police!
- Answer the question!
- Yeah, I mean, I like Disneyland,
but don't kill me about it.
- See even she likes Disneyland.
- [Homeowner] 911?
- Okay, so she likes it, people like it,
I don't like it, it's not for everybody.
- You are crazy!
- Hey,
you keep your voice down, okay?
We're professionals, you're on the job.
- I am so sorry, you're right.
- Hey, both of you, just listen.
How about tomorrow,
we take a little trip down to Disneyland?
- Just make a day out of it.
- Okay, okay I will try it,
but if I don't like it,
then that's the end of this.
- How about a group hug?
Huh? I'm feeling a group hug, let's do it.
- Let's go.
- [Justin] This is nice.
- [Small World] Mhmm.
(sirens)
- [All] Ohhh.
- I totally forgot we were in the middle
of a robbery and just got caught.
- Alright guys, Disneyland
in three to five years.
- Disneyland in three to five years.
(elated music)
(techno music)
(camera shutter)
(pleasurable music)